here in the Everglades the mating season
has arrived this amorous male gator who
appears to be alone
bellows his serenade d'amour and
performs his magnificent water dance to
attract a suitable cleaning his bellows
above water are audible underwater the
throaty vibrations he gargles forth are
too low for human ears for seasons but
the rumble agitates the suave in a
symphony of dancing waters we're pretty
sure this is the origin of the phrase
good vibrations he's not just feeling
good vibes he's sending off he's
oscillating like a radio transmitter
broadcasting on radio station ma te well
no surprise here it worked
the female has been seduced by that
Basso Rumble alligator foreplay to snout
rubbing that's how he shows he's a lover
as well as a fighter a truce is called
and they glide away who quenched their
hot Gator fever
you